the jurgen experience
this google
engineer that has come out and said that
he believes that the google ai sentient
because it says that it is sad it says
it's lonely it starts communicating and
you know
google is
they're it seems like they're in a
dilemma in that situation
first of all
if it is sentient
does it get rights right like does it
get days off
i had this conversation with my friend
duncan trussell last night and he was
saying imagine
if you you know if you have to give it
rights like is it does it get treated
like a human being like what is it
well i'll give you make it even a step
harder what if you copy it
right now you've got two of them well
that was what i said to ray kurzweil ray
kurzweil was talking at one point in
time about downloading consciousness
into computers and then he believes that
inevitably will happen and my thought
was like was going to stop someone from
downloading themselves a thousand times
right with some donald trump type
character just wants a million trumps
out there just
out there doing speeches like what what
would stop that yeah exactly so so let's
let's start with what this actually is
today which is i think you know which is
very interesting not well understood but
very interesting so what what google and
there's this other company open ai that
are doing these kind of text the text
bots that have the you know the the been
in the news
what they do it's it's a program it's an
it's an ai program it's basically it
uses a form of math called linear
algebra it's a very well-known form of
math but it uses a very complex version
of it and then basically what they do is
they've got complex math running on big
computers
and then what they do is they have what
they call training data and so what they
do is they basically slurp in a huge
data set from somewhere in the world and
then they basically train the math
against against the data to try to kind
of get it up to speed on how to interact
and do things
the training data that they're using for
these systems is all text on the
internet right so and all text on the
internet increasingly is a record of all
of human communication right all the
text on the internet all the text on the
internet so how does it capture all this
stuff well so google google's core
business is to be the cro is to do that
is to be the crawler you know famously
their mission organizer will information
they actually pull in all the text in
the internet already to make their
search engine work and then that's
that's and then the ai just scans that
and the ai basically uses that as a
training set right um and so and
basically just just basically chews
through and processes it it's a very
complex process but like chews through
and processes it and then the ai kind of
gets a converged kind of view of like
okay this is human language this is what
these people are talking about you know
and then it has all the statistical you
know once when a human being says x
somebody else says y or z or this would
be a
good thing to say or bad thing to say
for example you can get emotion you can
you can detect emotional loading from
text now so you can kind of determine
what the computer can kind of say this
text reflects somebody who's happy
because they're saying oh you know i'm
having a great day versus this text is
like i'm super mad you know therefore
it's upset and so you could have the
computer could get trained on okay if i
say this thing it's likely to make
humans happy if i just say this thing is
likely to make humans sad
but here's the thing it it it's all it's
all human generated text it's all the
conversations that that we've all had
and and so basically you load that into
the computer and then the computer is
able to kind of simulate right somebody
else having that conversation
um but but what happens is basically the
computer is playing back what people say
right right it's not it's not nobody no
no engineer the the guy who went through
this and did the the whistleblower thing
but he even said he didn't look at the
code he's not he's not in there like
working on the code everybody who works
in the code will tell you it's not alive
it's not conscious it's not having
original ideas what it's doing is it's
playing back to you things that it
thinks that you want to hear based on
all the things that everybody has
already said to each other
that it can get online and in fact
there's all these ways you can kind of
trick it into basic like for example you
can have it
he has this example where he like has it
where basically he said you know i want
you to prove that you're alive and then
the computer did all this stuff through
it's live you can do the reverse you can
say i want you to prove that you're not
alive and the computer will happily
prove that it's not alive and it'll give
you all these arguments as to why it's
not actually alive and of course it's
because it the computer has no view on
whether it's alive or not but it seems
like in in with with
this is all very weird
and
for sure we're in the fog of life if
it's not life it's in this weird fog of
like what makes a person a person like
what makes an intelligent thinking human
being that knows how to communicate able
to respond and answer questions well it
does it through cultural context does it
through understanding language and
having been around enough people that
have communicated in a certain way that
it emulates that right yeah so this is
the real question so this is where i was
headed the the real question is what
does it mean for a person to think right
like that's the real question and so and
so let's talk about there's something
called the turing test right which is a
little bit more famous now because the
movie the term made by alan turing so
the turing test basically in its
simplified form the turing test is
basically you're sitting in a computer
terminal you're typing in questions and
then the answers are showing up in the
screen there's a 50 chance you're
talking to a person sitting in another
room who's typing their responses back
there's a 50 chance you're talking to a
machine you don't know right you're the
subject and you can ask the entity on
the other end of the connection any
number of questions right he will he or
she or it will give you any number of
answers at the end you have to make the
judgment as to whether you're talking to
a person or talking to a machine
the the theory of the turing test is
when a computer can convince
a person that it's a person then it will
have achieved artificial intelligence
right then it will be as smart as a
person but but that begs the question of
like okay
like how easy are we to trick
right right like
and in fact and so actually it turns out
what's happened this is actually true
what's happened is actually there have
been chat bots that have been fooling
people in the turing test now for
several years
the easiest way to do it is with a sex
chatbot
because they're the most gullible
specifically specifically to men of
course that's why women are like way
less women probably fall for it a lot
less but men like you get a man on there
with a sex chat bot like the man will
convince himself he's talking to a real
woman like pretty easily even when he's
not right um and so just think of this
as a slightly more you know you could
think about this as a somewhat more
advanced version of that which is look
if if this thing if it's an algorithm
that's been optimized to trick people
basically to convince people that it's
real it's going to it's going to pass
the turing test even though it's not
actually conscious meaning it has no
awareness it has no
desire it has no regret it has no fear
you know it has none of the hallmarks
that we would associate with being a
living being like much less a conscious
being and so so this is this is the
twist and this is where i think this guy
google got got got kind of strung up a
little bit as or held up um is it the
the computers are going to be able to
trick people into thinking they're
conscious like way before they actually
become conscious
and then there's just the other side of
it which is like we have no idea we
don't know how human consciousness works
like we have no idea how the brain works
we have no idea how to like we have no
idea how to do any of this any any of
the stuff on people the the most
advanced form of medical science that
understands consciousness is actually
anesthesiology because they know how to
turn it off
[Laughter]
right they know how to click you know
power off and then power back on which
is also very important but like they
have no idea what's happening inside the
black box and we have no idea nobody has
any idea so so this is a
parallel line of technological
development that's not actually
recreating the human brain it's doing
something different it's basically
training computers and how to understand
process and then reflect back the real
world it's very valuable work because
it's going to make computers a lot more
useful for example self-driving cars
this is the same kind of work that makes
a self-driving car work yeah so this is
this is very valuable work
it will create these programs that will
be able to trick people very effectively
right and so so there for example here's
what i would be worried about which is
basically like what percentage of people
that we follow on twitter are even real
people
right yeah elon is trying to get to the
bottom of that right now he's trying to
get the bottom of that you know
specifically on that issue from the
business but just
also think more generally which is like
okay if you have a computer that's
really good at writing tweets if you
have a computer that's really good at
writing angry political tweets or
writing whatever absurdist you know
humor or whatever it is like and by the
way maybe the computer is going to be
better at doing that than a lot of
people are you know you could you can
imagine a future internet in which most
of the interesting content is actually
getting created by machines you know
there's this new system dolly um you
know that's getting a lot of visibility
now which is this thing where you can
type in any phrase and it'll create you
computer generated art right oh i've
seen that yeah they've done some with me
it's really weird yeah yeah you know
chase lepard he's got a few of them that
he put up on his instagram
how does that work yeah yeah so it's a
very similar thing so basically what
they do with the the google has one of
these and and open ai has one of these
what they do is they pull in all of the
images on the internet right so if you
you think about if you go to google
images or whatever just do a search you
know on any topic it'll give you
thousands of thousand images of you
whatever
and then basically they pull in all the
images um yeah that's me exactly
how bizarre yeah so that's so that's ai
generated art so that's ai generated art
that's a different program that's just
basically doing yeah sort of psychedelic
art the the the dolly ones are basically
they'll they're sort of composites
um where they will give you basically a
it's almost like an artist that will
give you many different drafts yeah
that's another one of me yeah so uh he
the first one he
go back to that please
yeah you just had it up it's what does
it say it said uh what joe rogan facing
the dmt realm insanely detailed
intricate hyper hyper masculinist miss
dark elegant ornate luxury elite horror
creepy ominous haunting moody dramatic
volumetric light ak render 8k post hyper
details so they say that and then they
enter all this stuff in and this is what
comes out and this is what comes out now
holy [ __ ] yes okay so first of all yes
it's incredible like that's amazing it's
an original work of art that is exactly
this back that didn't make my nose look
like that it doesn't really look like
that right
not today it's it's a little off i would
say if that was an artist like i think
you got the nose wrong and you made my
job well it's referencing these other
artists if you see at the end it's
actually referencing is probably pulling
in portraits right of other people from
those artists and using it to do a
composite thing right but the fact that
it can make art
no but see what it's doing right so it's
very impressive i mean the output's very
impressive and the fact that it can do
this impressive but it's being told
exactly what to do yes it didn't have
the idea that it was going to do that it
was told it was it's it's following
instructions right right so it's not
sitting it's not sitting there like a
real artist dreaming up new artistic
concepts right but here's the question
because you were you were saying this
before that it can trick people into
thinking it's real how do we know what's
what is alive
but this is the question
what is
a human consciousness interacting with
another human consciousness i mean it is
data
it is the understanding of the use of
language inflection tone
the vernacular that's used in whatever
region you're communicating with this
person in to make it seem as authentic
and normal as possible and you're doing
this back and forth like a game of
volleyball right
this is what language is and a
conversation is if a computer's doing
that
well it doesn't have a memory well but
it does have memory well it doesn't have
emotions is that what we are i don't
know because if that's what we are then
we're all that's all we are right
because the only difference is emotion
and maybe biological needs like the need
for food the need for sleep the need for
you know the for touch and love and all
the weird stuff that makes people people
the emotional stuff but if you extract
that
the the normal interactions that people
have on a day-to-day basis it's
it's pretty similar yeah yeah well so so
here would be the way to think about it
is like what's the difference between an
animal and a person right like why do we
grant people rights that we don't grant
animals rights and of course and of
course that's a hot topic of debate
because there are a lot of people who
think animals should have more rights
but but fundamentally we do we do have
this idea we have this idea of what
makes a human distinct from a horse or a
dog right is is is self-awareness right
as a sense of self a sense of self being
conscious right you know i i descartes i
think therefore i am right right and so
at least we have this concept with this
philosophical concept of consciousness
being something that involves
self-awareness like the computers the
computer is like i told you the computer
is quite capable of telling you it has
self-awareness yeah it's also quite
capable of telling you it doesn't
it doesn't care right it has no opinion
on whether it has consciousness or not
and that's why i'm confident that these
things are not conscious they're not
alive but these things
are they just it's just it's a program
it's a program it's a program yeah but
at what point in time does the program
figure out how to write better programs
right at what point in time does the
program fit figure out how to manifest a
physical object
that
can take all of its knowledge and all
the information that's acquired through
the use of the of the internet which is
the
basically the origin theme in ex machina
right the super scientist guy he's using
his web browser his his search engine to
scoop up all people's thoughts and ideas
and he puts them into his robots which
is basically what basically what what
these companies are doing hopefully
hopefully with a different result um
well let me bring there's another top
word hopefully
there's another there's another topic
the friend of a friend of mine peter
peter thielenaer's argue sergers is like
it's like basically he's like look us
you know civilization is declining you
can tell because all the science fiction
movies are negative
right like it's it's all dystopia
everybody's got hope for the future
everybody's negative and my answer is
just like the negative stories are just
more interesting right nobody nobody
makes the movie with like the happy ai
right like it's just not there's no
drama in it right so anyway that's why i
say hope hopefully it won't be
hollywood's dystopian vision but here's
another question though the nature of
consciousness right which is another
idea that the card had that i think
therefore i am guy had is he had this
idea of mind-body dualism which is also
what ray kurzweil has with this idea
that you'll be able to upload the mind
which is like okay there's the mind
which is like basically all of this you
know some level of software equivalent
coding something something happening and
how we do all the stuff you just
described then there's the body and
there's some separation between mind and
body where maybe the body is sort of can
be arbitrarily modified or is disposable
or could be replaced or replaced by a
computer it's just not necessary once
you upload your brain
and of course and this is a relevant
question for for the a for ai because of
course the ai dolly has no body you know
gpt3 has no body right well do we really
believe in
mind-body do we really believe mind and
body are separate like do we really
believe that and what the science tells
us is no they're not separate in fact
they're very connected right and a huge
part of what it is to be human is the
intersection point of of of of brain and
mind and then brain to rest the body for
example all the medical research now
that's going into the influence of gut
bacteria on behavior
right and then the sort of in the role
of viruses and how they change behavior
and like and so basically like i think
the most evolved version of this the
most sort of advanced version of this is
like whatever it means to be human it's
some combination of mind and body is
some combination of logic and emotion
it's some combination of mind and brain
it leads to us being the crazy creative
inventive destructive innovative
caring hating people we are right the
sort of mess yeah the mess that is
humanity right like that that's
that's amazing like that that you know
the the four billion years of evolution
that it took to get us to the point
where we're at today is like amazing and
i'm just saying like we don't know we
don't have the slightest idea how to
build that